over the last 25 years resident evil has
continually changed and evolved as
capcom has tried different mixes of
survival horror and action gameplay
with resident evil 7 capcom swung for
the fences with a first-person
perspective
and more classic horror-focused gameplay
its sequel resident evil village
evolves that idea to make something that
feels very different from its
predecessor
but which is just as engaging though the
perspective and the mechanical
underpinnings are the same
village branches off in its own
direction from re7
capturing some of the things that were
great about that game while resisting
the impulse to retread the same ground
while it's still frightening at points
it takes a less horror-driven tack
on the same formula village continues to
evolve resident evil
while maintaining a keen grasp on some
of its core tenets
finding new ways or reviving old ones of
getting under your skin and ratcheting
up the tension
where the hell am i
[Music]
as has been pretty clear for a while now
resident evil village is resident evil 7
through the lens of resident evil 4.
when the latter was released back in
2005
it totally revamped what the franchise
had been up to that point
swapping the earlier game slower
survival horror focus
for a more fast-paced action approach
trading darkened corridors and jump
scares
for adrenaline-fueled panic village adds
to re7
by taking its cues from the faster
panickier re4
it's again played from a tight closed in
first person perspective
and it still often focuses on slower
movement and exploration
but village's approach is distinctly
more action-centric
and it's remarkable how much capcom has
managed to push the underlying formula
of its reboot to the series
in such a different direction
village picks up on resident evil 7's
story three years later
again focusing on protagonist ethan
winters after rescuing his wife mia from
the baker house
and subsequently getting saved by
resident evil franchise mainstay chris
redfield
ethan and mia went into hiding with
chris's help moving to europe to restart
their lives
they've since had a daughter but their
lives are abandoned again when chris and
his team bust into the couple's house
and drag ethan and baby rose off ethan
wakes up sometime later after a car
crash
the two random special forces guys who
were transporting him and rose are dead
ethan wanders through the snowy woods in
search of his missing child
until he hits a ramshackle seemingly
empty village before long
he discovers it's under siege by what
appeared to be werewolves
it's all extremely reminiscent of the
beginning of resident evil 4
which upended the ari formula by
dropping you into a village overrun with
enemies
who acted like humans rather than
shambling mindless zombies
the likens you face wield weapons and
shoot arrows at you
and to avoid getting surrounded you can
run into houses and barricade the doors
with furniture to slow their advances
just like its 2005 inspiration the
opening battle of village taps into a
frightening intensity of trying to
create a defensible position
or take part in a running gunfight that
you're in serious danger of losing
it's a completely different feeling from
the slow burn dread of re7
but village's combat can make your heart
pound just as hard
the fact that village feels like such a
turn away from re7
is what works about it as a sequel it
feels like capcom reaching for a new way
to challenge itself
most of the time in village at least on
its standard difficulty
you'll find yourself pretty well
outfitted for whatever you're about to
face
the challenges in using those resources
effectively and keeping yourself alive
village uses the same movement system as
re7 which can feel a little slow and
clunky at times
eden isn't especially agile and even at
a sprint
it can feel like he's barely moving
despite a sense of trudging through mud
village is tuned so that enemies also
approach slowly and cautiously
so dealing with them comes together like
a standoff that has you judging their
moves
or hitting their weak points before they
have a chance to get in close
and rip into you and sometimes you just
have to run and hope you can find a
better place to make your stand
while the controls add tension when
you're surrounded they can be a bit
obtuse making it difficult to avoid
attacks
you're often dodging attacks as a
monster charges you or swings at you
with a huge weapon
you can absorb some damage with the
ability to hold up your hands in a guard
another re7 feature that helps mitigate
the limitations of your movement
but the better strategy is to try to run
around the battlefield and get out of
the way
that usually means sacrificing seeing
what your opponent is doing
since ethan can't step sideways while
looking forward you're constantly just
running and hoping whatever is coming at
you
doesn't hit you it doesn't make these
battles frustrating or add to their
difficulty
but it does add a counter-intuitiveness
to combat that can take you out of the
moment
bullets are easy to come by and if
you're short you can craft more from
materials you find
or purchase them from the duke a
traveling merchant all
that stuff you're carrying around has to
go somewhere so village brings back the
inventory management system of re4
you have a suitcase full of weapons ammo
and health items with each taking up
space on a grid
you can move items around to make sure
they all fit in your case tetris
style and purchase bigger cases from the
duke so you can bring more stuff
the system is most interesting when it
starts making you wonder if you should
sell off old guns or toss less useful
items
in favor of things like extra ammo
mercifully
crafting items don't count against your
inventory space so you're free to make
bullets and health items on the fly
on standard difficulty it was never a
big concern but you do have to start
thinking about keeping space open as you
explore
in case you find something essential
though village has far more variety of
enemies to fight than re7
it's not all shooting with a lot of
varied pacing and new challenges
throughout
there are four different areas to unlock
as you progress through the story
each headed by one of the four lords the
scary monster people who dominate the
village
and the area around it after the opening
village the first is the castle run by
lady dimitresk
where there's a lot less shooting to be
done you'll occasionally face enemies
you have to gun down
but much more time in the castle is
spent navigating its tight corridors
as you're hunted by the vampire
demotrask and her daughters
you can't kill the vampires with your
conventional weapons so you have to run
if you're found
the entire level is spent exploring the
castle looking for the items you need to
advance through the area
while listening for dimatresk's clumping
footsteps and trying to keep away from
her
even in this first new area village is
mixing and remixing its experience
with different horror ideas you're not
just shotgunning a ton of enemies
you're also engaging in stealth more
akin to what navigating the baker house
was like in re7
and later portions of the game throw
different obstacles into your path
there are areas that are full of puzzles
that are reminiscent of the mansion of
resident evil
or the police station of re2 there are
sections where you hear frightfully
powerful enemies in the distance you
know you'll have to fight
and there are points that show village
can still hone in on some of the intense
frights that made re7
so remarkable suffice to say that
village is great at maintaining an
atmosphere of unease
as you head around each new corner sure
you have plenty of weapons
but can you handle what you're about to
face will they even work against
the next creature you encounter there's
an excellent balance between providing
lots of action
and maintaining that dread village
encourages its own kind of fear
and hits you with a few great re7 like
set pieces
to ratchet up the tension when you least
expect it no two sections of village are
quite the same
each draws on different aspects of past
resident evil games and combines them
with that underlying
re7 feel to create something that's both
new and nostalgic
it's impressive how the game can change
to be a little different
again and again throughout its run time
mixing in other ideas from the franchise
to make each section
fun intense and naturally frightening in
its own way
the exception to that is the last hour
of the game where things take a weird
over-the-top turn in the run-up to
village's final moments
the action gets turned up even higher it
seems like a needless digression
where village draws on the worst
action-heavy portions of resident evil 6
losing track of what made you grit your
teeth and clench your fists
and exchanging it for something more
akin to shooters like call of duty
this same moment highlights some of the
inconsistency in village's story
though the game's imagery recalls the
umbrella logo from past games
village's connection to the rest of the
franchise feels a bit tacked on
the same is true of chris redfield whose
presence in the story
feels like an afterthought ethan's
interactions with the four lords and the
mystery of the village
is more fun and interesting since the
antagonists come off as petty
flawed and human they don't particularly
like each other
but are all eager to torture and maim
you anyway
and their interactions with ethan and
each other add dimension to their
characters
likens and gentlemen
we thank you and now let the games begin
village is a spooky romp with fun
villains but it's just a shame that more
time wasn't devoted to the hanging story
threads
of re7 or the franchise at large
thankfully
that digression doesn't last long
meanwhile the elements about combat that
are fun
are transplanted into the fast-paced
arcade mode
the mercenaries the mode takes the
combat of the village
slaps a timer on it and focuses it on
scoring points
the mercenaries is a fun side activity
in its own right
always daring you to get a higher score
by balancing taking down as many enemies
as you can
and trying to complete one of its given
levels as fast as you can
it demonstrates how tight the combat and
village can be
although at times it can be held back a
bit by the slow underwater feeling of
movement around the battlefield
resident evil 7 was an excellent return
to the horror roots of the franchise
with some coming new ideas similarly
village is an intelligent reimagination
of the best action elements
of resident evil though it captures some
of the same things that made re7
such a breath of fresh air village uses
new takes on the ideas of the past
to evolve into its own unique creature